[Musique]
vous arrivez ici à saint tropez ouais je
suis de paris trois arrondissements
projet ouais avec avec cette robe comme
ça il doit rester sinon c'est pas très
marrant je voudrais je trouve que c'est
super mais je dis ouais c'est vrai
qu'ils ont plus ou moins les couches
beauvais c'est dommage que je vais
revenir à la baisse le coût je vais avec
sont prononcés dans le dessin c'est une
propriété dans les pages je suis fâché
et c'est toujours comme ça avec les
femmes puis il a pris beaucoup de jeunes
flics n'est pas que ça m'arrive quoi
écouter des parties fines autour des 6
et 10 minutes
ce diminue ouais
qu'est ce que vous voulez
je t'emmène la voiture bien je te dépose
ailleurs
n'aura laissé prendre au piège
c'est déjà touché la cime de flip
sapporo ouais surtout soit 5 go beaucoup
s'y met tous petits d'accord alors j'ai
aussi à oui oui oui on fait attention
ces jeux qu'on espérait quand même en
partie bayel commissariat qui est la
bonne
c'est vrai bon ben alors j'aurai mon
papier papier regardes tu veux dire que
tout est en règle et tout va bien moi
pour mieux regarder mais pas au football
ouais bon mais ça a été une bonne soirée
bah oui part de m
robert abadie
voyez qu'en fin de compte est la raison
de ce qu'elle dit c'est pas vrai mais
que vous soyez belle bien joli ratio
haut bas coût avec non générale
heureusement elles sont belles
non c'est vrai bah c'est gentil vous
êtes bien jeune ba était tout va des
polices nationales ça sympa et tout est
en règle quand tout va bien depuis les
gentils en plus avec tout le monde c'est
vrai bain de nature
c'est un bon mari non mais ça va pas
trouver ce que tu voulais pour n'a
jamais pensé à lui j'ai pris devant j'ai
pris une part de tarte tropézienne pour
mamie pour quel bout de femme est malade
en fait un bond de plus de 30 jours
batoul été appliquée et mettez des
points mon père me poser
c'est qu'on va le jour tient pas mais
revoir fait un beau voyage
ce fut un centre bon c'est pas pour ça
non savoir se déroule au savoir au pont
jolies filles comme vous c'est trop bon
pourquoi voudriez m'aider ouais tu m'as
pas la diffuser sa côte est à la côte
est avec moi oui oui je vois et je
faisais bien c'est vrai elle est
sacrément ici un cordon vous avez une
belle couleur brune est en plein dedans
je suis ici je fais des projets
vous avez des yeux vous verrez
la ferme et vous ça vous plaît safari
j'avais une côte italienne
c'est vrai j'ai vu un bébé
la présidente est mme pastel des encore
qu'avant que d'autres ken peng que des
portraits où nous serions mandela
non
ouais qu'est ce que vous seriez prêt à
faire pour moi j'aime tant de belles
choses
[Musique]
dis-moi dis-moi un truc comme ça jamais
fait ça
ceci engendre une oreille là dans sa
version allongée sur un pantalon je suis
à bord de mer dans une chambre blanche
avec moquette blanche et alpha qui comme
ça je sais déshabille et je prends une
boîte de rouge à lèvres des rouges à
lèvres
ouais je me mets du rouge à lèvres et je
te couvre le corps entier de baiser
jusqu'à ce qu'ils soient complètement
rouge actuelle
non c'est pas facile à être couvertes
les voir car la mise en garde par les
lèvres du non mais
quant à 6 ouais mais fait délicate
elle-même comme des baisers d'oiseaux y
parvenir la chose noire et après les
bébés
je resterai pas sous main ou un peu
immobilité là je fais des bisous
bisous des bisous vraiment rsa way
mais
grosse préparation
avant la parade grosse prestation avant
l'introduction comme common orchestre me
raconter souvent c'est beau c'est beau
si tu le désires attention ce n'est pas
une obligation
ce n'est pas une obligation ouais il
faut que les deux parties soient
d'accord pour la chose non parce que
j'ai horreur de ça je suis pas le mec il
dit bon je vous
vous et perles vous amènera ici je
menais et puis ça quoi avoir tous les
droits
ouais ouais ne dites pas ça vous fait
l'amour c'est l'amour c'est que
romantique
baiser sais pas si c'est pas joli ce
problème c'est si beau que tu dis je
t'assure c'est impossible
j'en ai le coeur tout bouleverser non
mais c'est vrai je dis pas n'importe qui
unique
[Musique]
d'accord il va tu faisais lula mardi
opposable
ouais ouais ouais j'ai peur pacy georgie
des vitamines b12
ouais bon
aucun canton ne s'occupe sur le ban
[Musique]
exploité sur la plage avec son chien
pour voir les filles non parce que
qu'est-ce que vous faites puisque tout
en vacances notre jeu se voir poser une
heure exactement
ouais je veux arriver là ce que vous
parlais tout à l'heure c'est un battant
ouais aux trois semaines cherche un peu
des copains
bah ouais ça vous irez vous faire
visiter la région éventuellement
pourquoi pas sourire ouais ouais c'est
sûr je connais vraiment personne aussi
oublier la crème nous emmène dans la
crème du temps mais ce côté blanc
allaient ouais c'est bon j'ai su percer
regardez mon sac je vais aller au petit
coin
merci billets pas demain je fais
confiance à l'épaulé jeté la connaissez
mais pourquoi il est arrivé comme ça moi
j'ai connu cela beats et 3 janvier
voilà la taille de sa poitrine 1 1 voilà
là vraiment le faire visiter la région
elle avance soit une passe
[Musique]
vous tapez commun la prépa je te mettre
la crème mais je peux quand même savoir
que j'étais foutu à la porte une fois
tous les deux mois
tous les trous sur lesquels toute la
plage ensemble
ah non non je vous ai choisis vous
[Musique]
tenaille croquer un morceau de quoi
garder les rondeurs web des way une
belle poitrine au bois pas trop hein on
voit pas trouvé beaucoup de vent pour
rêver d'un côté regarde on voit voilà on
se donne rendez vous au pont comme a
permis à fazeli ch passe des boules
quiès
le chanceuse et marie a beaucoup de
charme
mais sa vie et oui ça
ah oui vous avez de la chance
la mairie a oui ça on me l'avait dit
salut affirmant
ça va pas
ça va
cette manie carrément foot
je laisse la rentrée mais tant pis je
n'en mets pas de charme et puis j'ai
passé l'âge mais c'est pas vrai elle
vous prennent ou pour s'assurer fait
quelques beaux jours
bon ça syrie a fait présent genre c'est
vraiment charmant s'est pas inquiété
pour ça non je ne m'inquiète pas pour sa
maman
je m'étais trop beau comme chaque année
là si précieux non annonce du gazole y
en a plus c'est le signe d'un charmant
oui c'est vrai il est très très très
beau on viendrait me revoir c'est vrai
tout ça c'est important
ça va mieux ah bon je vais pas te
remonter moralement ça va pas
avant ça va alors on va savourer cocol
le programme le joli
ça c'est aujourd'hui j'ai trouvé
mignonne ouais quand même bien j'étais
plus jeune on est capable à n'importe
quel âge
ces marchands comme je comprends bien
même incident heureusement deux soirs au
jour en jour plus de goût oui ça c'est
sûr bah il faudra essayer des monomères
mais comment ce soir ce soir chez toi je
frappe c'est vrai ce soir chez toi
non
sur la plage tu as déjà fait ça sur la
plage
t'aimes pas pour le monde encore et
toujours
ah ouais ça s'appelait ouais ouais ouais
ça va retomber sous les gravats c'est
vrai quand tu t'appelles bon vraiment à
ça fait rêver vraiment pas qu'on ait des
halles vraiment c'est bien l'amour quand
est ce que vraiment on va me trouver ça
a comme en temps tu as carrément on va
me trouver quand il fait ça
baba
et les femmes
un petit air pourquoi tel jeune fille
le fameux thé simplement de la prochaine
lui parler ouais j'ai jamais francophone
après il y en a - 4 pen je suis le
mortel ou pas et moi ce que je te
connais un petit peu ou beaucoup c'est
vrai ces jaloux tu me regardais toujours
pas vu dans un habillage non non mais
c'est pas beaucoup encore d'expérience
c'est d'avoir beaucoup d'expérience toi
on peut quand même
aimerais tu viens me chercher à 19
heures ce soir je réfléchirai à la
couture et ça fait plaisir mais vrai
j'ai dû à ces écoles sont déjà plus
alalalala fort à faire bon d'accord
allait garder sourire et dynamique
ciao
oh ça va
ah bah ouais c'est pas trop mal voilà la
jambe s'est abîmé voilà juste maintenant
ouais et le scooter
[Musique]
ohlala pas de chance dis donc s'ils se
glisse la is in a way couteau si vous
alliez à saint tropez ou tel sens
vacances vous avez des intellos tel ou
tel le provençal à baja c'est là où je
dois aller
oui j'ai gilbert et christine que vous
avez pris un petit vélo santé désolé
ben alors c'est ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui
écoutez madame ça c'est des journées que
je retiendrai de votre
non non mais vraiment j'ai eu un monde
fou et j'aurais fait le double avec vous
je suis furieux
casanova je vais devoir vous savez à la
jumelle en voiture pour vous avez vous
aviez ou au bas je me baladais mais vous
êtes fait mal à la mangue et boit du
whisky à je vais pas vous faire un autre
accident mais menée chez voir jouer au
même jeu vous jouez bien sûr je vous
amène chez moi bien sûr
en plus je suis tout seul en plus en ce
moment alors je trop mignonne avant toi
oui vous êtes quel français manches
canadiennes et canadiens
avant oui deux frères que je rivalise
alors avec elle une canadienne soit chez
moi et justement il ya un bon dîner il
ya des adducteurs qui vont tout le monde
qui sont changeants changement
[Musique]
carrément ouais tu fais les choses
toujours comme ça non
ce qui m'a pris oui je voudrais la
sympathique parce que bonjour ça bien
tout à fait autrement
sur marie oui je suis donné au niveau
des méridiens oui oui oui mais tu en
réponse lui je suis arrivé hier j'ai
fait toute la côte du bien de toi
ao je suis bien entouré gardes du corps
après s'être trompé
et tu t'es là pour combien de temps tu
sais pas je la prends des français tu
parles déjà bien français auront bien
wahlberg évoqué ce week end là qu'est ce
que c'est peu dire en mai au grand chose
dis-moi comment tu t'appelles
non tu sais déjà comment tu me tues moi
je te prends couple ayem veut ouais non
oh
vous
les matheux fait un jogging j'essaye
je vais nager sport non j'ai pas que
faire l'amour c'est pas mal non plus
comme sport ça dit pas comment vous à
pratiquer est ce que les etats-unis
c'est au sport ici je sais pas les
français quand vous savez ça c'est faux
situation est proposé et vous êtes 2 il
faut avoir un jaloux nos problèmes à
trois matches comme ça y'a pas de jaloux
waouh
à tête et des yeux et où je pourrai
dormir mais tu veux c'est où le plus
romantique pour motiver les plages pas
loin à ce que vous avez déjà fait
l'amour à toi non non merci
si on n'essaie rien dans la vie on n'a
pas tous les ans c'est aussi la
politique scientifique et il me dévoile
des yeux ou je sens que ça va être le
paradis ce soir tu en france j'aime bien
la langue française vous faites encore
une vision d'un coup avec l'enseigné
kiss me remets tout
[Musique]
la baignade
moi je conduirai en soit on voit la
hongroise et quatre femmes c'est pour
moi les yeux
et ouais voilà comment on fait pour
draguer dans votre région c'est dur
comme moi c'est une blague et comment
vous feriez déjà un peu quand c'est
parce que toi y sera pas facile je sais
pas
en collant pas un peu en froid l' arrêt
par exemple gt gt pas parti sur l'idée
quoi avant et vous vous cachez pas à la
pêche aux femmes ont moins
alors oui t'as réfléchit un peu pour ce
soir là bas malgré tout que je suis
fatigué vincent pour le yoga c'est vrai
oui
qu'est ce qu'on va faire ce soir
tandis qu'en face
pour avoir les idées 5 millions us ce
massage sans doute au fond c'est
sûrement les massages qualité pendant
les matches non pas du tout non pollué
tôt ouais mais si tu te laisses un peu
inspiré bon je leur aurais mieux fait
fort il me semble je vais essayer de
pêcher un poisson quand tu prends ma
cuisine je suis pas plu du tout enfin ça
sera pas alors
je fais la bonne cuisine alors bon c'est
tout bon comme j'adore manger c'est vrai
qu'il y aille dormir manger et puis
c'est tout ce que je sais faire aussi
faire l'amour voilà on a passé toute la
nuit il partie de la nuit et le reste on
a les résultats je dors bien récupérer
un peu en fait tu sais que dimanche et
on connaît en réalité ces ventes
effectives crush on va dire que méchante
alors est d'accord mais le problème
c'est que tu dois finir un quart à lui à
l'ordinateur
non et comprendra
[Musique]
les petites robes rester à munich en
phase critique sera pas tout va y passer
alors un pâle facilement temps là le
prométhée guette pas on est servis les
premiers qui cartonnait non mais oh tu
vois ça n'a pas duré et je suis premier
à attaquer mais l'attaqué mérite à bloc
tout un peuple système
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour ce soir
dagan et colère parce que c'est des
copains depuis longue date au nom non
seulement la absolue qui me freine plus
belle la plus belle des déclarations
d'amour remportera ce soir alors
j'attends c'est déjà un départ allez je
te ferai un petit massage ce soir aux
portes quoi il va pas être trop jaloux
pourquoi pas je pense pas nantes est
important pour nous tous les deux cas le
coeur qui bat depuis les cinq dernières
minutes et ce qu'ils bossent vraiment
plus vite comme on dit chez moi et bas
tout en guitares donc des cas une jeune
demoiselle tout de suite et crack
c'était deux fois déclaration ah bon et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou